have you guys gotten to the time jump
part of the story line yet
almost uh next week we start the time
jump it's actually seven years later
which is
green you genuinely believe that
if the monologue fits riverdale is back
you guys are filming season five right
now i was so excited to see you on set
in front of pops what's the vibe like
for season five as you guys are
are trying to film amidst the background
of
the pandemic it's a little much
the vibe is good i think everyone's like
you know are we ever going to go back to
work kind of thing
normally we'd be shooting in july yeah
so we didn't start till
you know end of september so i think
everyone's just kind of happy to be
working again also it's a little hard
because like i you know you can see i'm
in canada
you can't leave once you're here so
normally we're all used to like doing
you know we have a couple days off fly
back to la for the weekend
you can't go you can't go once you're
here that's it and we had the quarantine
and for two weeks in the hotel room and
it's it's a it's a lot but you know
people are really excited about
us coming back and i'm really happy that
we can do that and i'm grateful for the
work you know
and plus i'm only recurring this year so
i can they can put all my stuff at once
i get to go home for a chunk
come back for chunk um because you know
i'm working on other stuff and it's
it's it's actually working out fairly
well so i can't really complain
well i'm just so excited that we are
getting you for season five because like
you said you're now recurring this
season because
you were gonna be done after season four
and i think i
broke the news with roberto that he was
gonna ask to bring you back
because we had some leftover hermione
business to wrap up
take me through that journey what was
what was causing you to want to step
away from riverdale and what brought you
back
um okay so how do i put this
it's a good question man is it that
riverdale's become a little much
no it wasn't necessarily
a choice okay oh well then that makes me
upset
it's just kind of what happens and okay
let me how how about this you know me
how about i paint this picture
they were gonna be doing the time jump
for season five and they said they
wanted to focus on the younger actors
and that they
there we go there we go let's do that
okay
all right so now we're on the same page
a little bit so
now that we are getting to see hermione
in season five because you guys do need
to wrap up
that storyline before the time jump what
can we expect from her
well one of the things that was really
really important for me um if i was
going to come back and wrap things up or
or
do some more episodes was that hermione
stick up for herself
yes it was really bothering me that she
was in for all
sense and purposes kind of an abusive
relationship and she
changed who she was to be with hiram
and you know not that she's innocent but
it bothered me yeah bothered me just as
a woman
you know i wanted to see her have some
strength and some power and stand on her
own two feet
and not be stupid to for lack of a
better work
so that was really important to me and
roberto um
really honored that and i'm very happy
about what i'm doing so far
so word of advice get back in line with
this family
because you are a lodge before anything
else
have you guys gotten to the time jump
part of the storyline yet
almost uh next week we start the time
jump please tell me we're going to see
hermione
in the time job oh yeah yeah yeah it's
gonna be fun i'm excited what can you
tease
um she doesn't look that different
because you don't age
i was trying to think of like what do i
want to do and i was like nothing this
woman has all the money in the world i'm
sure she gets everything done i'm like
it's fine
what can you tease about what hermione's
daughter is up to what is veronica like
five years later
she um it's actually seven years later
which is crazy
i know i like that i would say what i
can
tease is that you know and it's true
about life
when you're a teenager relationships are
very complicated
complicated right and they get sometimes
too serious or you're
not sure if you like this one you like
that one well that follows you along
as you grow up and it doesn't
necessarily get easier
and we will see that with um we'll see
that lebron what can you tease about
hermione
and uh hiram's dynamic
i want her to be free of him um let's
just say
i'm on that same page and i think i'll
leave it there
i love the fact that you posted a photo
with you and machine and skeet
and molly it warmed my heart so much um
can we expect to see more of those
parent scenes together
yeah i believe so i think so i mean if
you're gonna have you're gonna do a time
jump and you're gonna have parents
involved i think
i think riverdale will always bring them
and kind of suck them back in
maybe because you'll see us together but
it was i mean it was great that was the
first day i've seen everyone and
you know since like february since we
sat down so it was really it was really
nice it was a really nice reunion
definitely and and not to bring the tone
down but i would be remiss if i didn't
acknowledge the fact that
it was what would have been luke perry's
54th
birthday it's so hard because i still
drive on set
and i he's the first thing i think of
because he was so much a part of
my first season you know he was the
driving force it was just you know
him and veronica and it's still it's
hard i still do the double take of like
i i it's hard it's still hard yeah do
you have a memory that you think about
when it comes to luke this crosses your
mind more than others
so many i would say yeah there was
during the
pilot we did the screening right um of
pilot and the kids the kids but the kids
were in the sitting in the front row and
you know and they didn't no one knew
what was gonna happen with riverdale or
whatever
and me and luke are sort of sitting
together and like watching them and
watching the screen and he leans over to
music they're the younger
90210 just watch and he was right
that's amazing that's so sweet that's so
sweet
um so we are getting seven years ahead
in riverdale
we're going into season five contracts
aside how long do you think riverdale
will go on for
i mean i would say at least two more
years if not
more you know it's it's
it's really nice to be on a show that's
so embraced by fans and riverdale became
sort of a
phenomenon and i can't imagine the
network letting go of that too
quick now that being said everyone
signed a seven year contract
so it'll depend on you know whether they
want to come back or not
exactly exactly do you feel like season
five
is a bit more on track because we really
went off the rails there
the last two seasons um
it's it's too soon to tell i don't put
the scripts ahead of time
i really i don't like i literally have
read four scripts and that's it and i
never know what's happening or what's
going to happen
i have ideas but that's about it so you
know
we'll see